como tú has dicho Hace algunos minutos
también se ha conocido de información
por parte de la secretaría Nacional de
atención a personas privadas con la
libertad básicamente lo que emite un
comunicado sobre lo que se ha realizado
el día de hoy Cuáles han sido las causas
que han motivado estos motivos estos
enfrentamientos el día de hoy se conoció
luego de que el presidente de la
república y diera información a través
de su cuenta en las redes sociales
Twitter donde él afirmaba que habían
sido trasladado dos cabecillas de la
banda Los Lobos y de la CR7 a una cárcel
de máxima seguridad debes tomar en
cuenta que en Ecuador operan por lo
menos es siete bandas dedicadas al
narcotráfico y cada una hace vida en los
distintos centros penitenciarios del
país y también por el control del
territorio y también por la lucha de
rutas del narcotráfico por el cual el
día de hoy han sido un poco divergentes
las cifras la fiscalía habla de nueve
cadáveres por una investigación que se
ha abierto y la el servicio nacional
integral las personas privadas de la
libertad habla de 8 cadáveres pero
cifras que se va actualizando ya
inclusive de 10 personas que son
resultado muertas por este último
enfrentamiento por el cual la cifras se
van actualizando poco a poco pero
Quiénes son estas personas bueno
cabecillas de bandas narcos delictivas
que se ha dicho ya que se han aislado en
una cárcel de máxima seguridad han sido
otros lados desde el inca que sirve la
ciudad de Quito a la cárceles de la roca
una cárcel de máxima seguridad ubicada
en la ciudad de Guayaquil y Gustavo que
medidas está llevando a cabo el gobierno
para intentar controlar esta situación
bueno básicamente en principio el día de
hoy sea alertado de que tres personas
más privadas de libertad de las bandas
del narcotráfico específicamente hablaba
de Los Lobos serán trasladados a la roca
esto serían tres personas más que serían
trasladados Próximamente a una cárcel de
máxima de seguridad pero básicamente El
Ejecutivo nacional ha dicho que
desarrolla un plan estratégico de
seguridad que no se conoce todavía a
dicho ejecutivo nacional que no lo
presentará por materias de seguridad
pero lo único que se ha hecho evidente
ha sido reuniones tanto con autoridades
de seguridad del gobierno de Israel De
igual forma también se ha visto
reuniones con el gobierno de los Estados
Unidos con representantes del Comando
sur y De igual forma también para poder
desarrollar la adquisición de equipo y
operaciones de emergencia para poder así
atacar el narcotráfico en este país en
el momento que se ha producido ya la
masacre número 12 desde el 21 de febrero
de 2021 hasta el día de hoy